so once in a while in a q a or in a
video I will mention in passing
something like subtle bodies
usually the context where I will mention
that is when we talk about angels and
the manner in which the church fathers
describe angels and so I thought I could
maybe give some of my own Insight on
this question now it's important to
understand that my insight is mostly
there to help connect the ancient way of
thinking with a more contemporary way of
thinking because sometimes we look at
the ancient way of thinking and we're
such materialists that we struggle to
see what it is that the fathers or the
Ancients are referring to when they talk
about something like subtle bodies
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
and so would we first of all what are we
talking about when we were talking about
subtle bodies so the idea is that
there are some beings and angels are the
way that is usually described that do
not have Corporal bodies like we they
don't have physical bodies like we do uh
but they're not also completely
spiritual that is they they exist in a
kind of intermediary realm in which they
have what we could call or what the
church fathers call subtle bodies now
the church fathers don't completely
agree on this you'll find obviously
different types of descriptions and some
of the fathers tend to oppose
materiality and immateriality very
clearly and so in that sense they'll say
angels are immaterial but sometimes
there's an intermediary like you talk
about uh let's say Spirit soul and body
uh or mind soul and body it depends how
you translate it but sometimes there's
like a triple idea and you have this
in between space uh which is what we
could call the space of subtle bodies
now I'm going to read a little text from
you from Saint John damascine and it'll
help you see
why it is that it can cause some
confusion all right and so
so here's Saint John damascine on angels
so he says that that God he himself and
the maker and creator of the angels He
had the maker and the creator of the
angels for he brought them out of
nothing into being and created them
after his own image an income income
corporeal race a sort of
Spirit of immaterial fire in the words
of the Divine David he makes his angels
spirit and his ministers a flame of fire
now notice already the problem that
we've got here now
you know we say angels are Wind and Fire
and so the way that we understand Wind
and Fire is that they are material
things and so we have lost in some
manner the analogy that the Ancients
used to use about the things which were
invisible the things which were
ungraspable even in the physical world
as ways to signify that which is
immaterial in the strict sense that is
things that don't have bodies like ideas
like uh you know like virtues like you
know the things that activate bodies
they themselves are not embodied you
could say they they don't have bodies
but and so you can see already the
problem so it's like you know these
angels are are made of of Wind and Fire
and so already a material this can read
that and think well they are material
they do have bodies they're made of Wind
and Fire but you can see even he makes
this effort to say that they are a sort
of spirit of material fire right and so
he's using the analogy of the physical
world to describe something which is
incorporeal in the strict sense okay and
so
he later goes on to try to
explain this and it's difficult right
because
he says the Angel's nature is rational
and intelligent and endowed with free
will changeable in will
uh for all that is created Created is
changeable and only that which is
uncreated is unchangeable and so the
very definition of creation is that it
is changeable only God is completely
unchangeable all right and then he
continues on to describe this saying
that they can turn towards goodness or
towards evil but they are not
susceptible to repentance because the
angels are incorporeal
all right so here is a good description
of something that can confuse someone
and so he says talking about angels
again seeing that they are Minds
they are in mental places they are not
circumscribed after the faction of a
body for they have not a bodily formed
by Nature nor are they extended in three
dimensions
but whatever post they may be assigned
there they are present after the manner
of a mind and energized and cannot be
present and energized in various places
at the same time and so
you know this can cause serious
confusion because you can think well
that means that angels are
you might think that it means that
angels are physically located that they
have that they're in certain places in
certain time but that's not what he's
saying he's saying there are in mental
places and they are circumscribed by
mental places and so you know the idea
you could understand it very simply that
you know something
you know a mental activator let's say
the angel of of uh of uh
of a virtue
let's say the the Angel of Hope
cannot also be the angel of Faith
because they are circumscribed by an
activating they're an activating
principle for for Hope for that aspect
of reality that is they they're given a
role they have a role in the world to
manage certain aspects of reality and
they are circumscribed by that role not
circumscribed physically in the world
but it's because we're so not used to
thinking that way we struggle to
understand what it is that we need and
so
you know that's why many of the the
church fathers will talk about the
notion that angels have what we call
subtle bodies which is that they're not
completely incorporeal in some ways God
only is completely
incorporeal but that their bodies are
not also con circumscribed in flesh but
they have
more fluid bodies more subtle bodies and
so it's difficult again and I and I one
of the reasons why I'm talking about
this is because I was reading
peralandria again and there's some
really wonderful C.S Lewis's book
there's some wonderful insights in that
book uh and also out of a silent out of
the Silent Planet uh there's some
wonderful insights but some of them can
be very in my opinion can be misleading
because the perception of these angels
is really uh uses a lot of material but
maybe he's doing it just because he
knows the story and there's no other way
to talk about it but he talks about you
know beings that are kind of made of
light almost in a physical way it seems
like that's what he seems to be
describing uh that are you know that are
kind of like another dimensions of all
that kind of stuff but I think that when
we go down that line too much as
materialists we lose an understanding of
what it is that we can mean by a body of
light or a body a subtle body you know
it's like a body of light means that
it's a body that
projects meaning onto other bodies it's
it's a it's a body a spiritual body that
is circumscribed because it's doing a
certain thing but it's also but it's
projecting light on other bodies it's
making sense of other things and so you
can understand uh and so we all like you
know you all of us have subtle bodies in
that sense all of us also have a
physical body but also a subtle body
that is ways that we influence
the world without being directly
physically connected to them and so our
very capacity to make meaning is in some
ways a form of subtle body so a good
example would be you know when you look
at uh you know stories of uh fairy tales
or kind of fantasy stories where they
talk about magicians who act at a
distance you know and so you could come
up with really elaborate you know weird
kind of new age materialist spiritualist
ideas about some like subtle substance
right was it Edgar case came up with the
idea of ectoplasm which is an actual
physical substance by the way which is a
subtler physical substance that can make
the magician you know act at a distance
like all that kind of nonsense but
the idea of action at a distance through
a subtle body is something that you do
every single day and it is quite normal
all you need to do to experience it is
to I don't know ask your child to bring
you a glass of water and then watch the
child bring you a glass of water that is
a subtle body that is action at a
distance through meaning making through
intelligence and not through actual
physical uh you know like physically
taking your child to the water and then
having them bring the water to you you
are using your subtle body to affect
reality and so that is the best way to
kind of understand what subtle bodies
are they're related to meaning they're
related to meaning making and they
energize the you know like a mind
energizes a body they energize bodies to
to move according to the role that they
play according to the intelligence that
they participate in and so that is
honestly like the just the best way to
understand a subtle body so you can
think about subtle bodies like try to
find example examples of subtle bodies
in the world and so a story for example
is a subtle body a story uh is a is not
encompassed in the world you can't you
know you can write down the story but
even the writing down of it is not the
story the story is a series of of of uh
a series of intelligent points that are
brought together in in a coherent whole
and that has an effect on people and so
if I tell a story I can affect you
through my subtle body so that it will
change the way that you act it I can
bring you under my you know under my
spell if you will or under my management
by using tools of meaning and tools of
of intelligent projecting right and so
that is the kind of the way to
understand it so
you know you could say something like
let's say uh especially the the notion
of angels that often especially the
lower Angels right so let's say the
angels and the archangels and the and
the um the guardian angels you know we
in some ways are their bodies you know
because they act on us they receive from
God and they act on us and then we
embody the patterns that they rule over
as we as we function in the world but
it's it's a it's a dangerous way it's a
dangerous to think that that's the only
way to understand it because the higher
levels of angels they are they don't act
directly on us they act through other
angels on on the bodies and they also
act through intelligent means for humans
to or to other humans and so very very
high angels are so subtle that the type
of pattern that they manage is so high
that it manages other patterns the best
way to understand it and so it's like
one Angel has other Angels below them
and then those angels also act on the
world etc etc until you get to the
corporeal World which is mannered
managed by this hierarchy of of of
agency above it
a hierarchy of patterns that comes down
upon reality and so you could say that
all these other levels are in some ways
the bodies of the higher beings but they
they're not necessarily corporeal
they're not necessarily physical bodies
that that extend into three dimensions
Saint John damisting says that they
don't extend in three dimensions you
know the the angel of the angel of uh of
Hope does not extend in three dimensions
it acts through us and it finds you know
it Finds Its anchor through us but the
way that it act on us is like a mind
energizing the world and so I think I
think it's important and I hope that you
can kind of understand and it would be a
good example to to think of examples of
subtle bodies like for example you know
if you if you write books even the
internet is very much an uh a
participation a subtle body that is the
the type of influence that you have
online by writing posts by posting
things by you know uh writing comments
these are subtle influences they're not
um
they're not like uh how can I say
there's not like me hitting someone over
the head with a baseball bat their
action at a distance they're subtle
different subtle influences that are an
extension of my own uh subtle body and
so a good way to to understand let's say
the subtle body is a is to understand
the notion that
my uh one part of the extension of me
one part of the manifestation of me is
one which is related to meaning and to
uh you know to to meaning making
that's a good way to understand it to
Spirit in that sense and and what's Also
let's say the last part of what I want
to say is that although I'm pushing
towards helping you or see the
difference right to not confuse when the
when the Holy fathers say something like
uh that the angels are made of uh of
immaterial fire to not confuse it with a
type of of
corporeality you know in a science
fiction way that you know they're
they're there but they're in another
dimension or that kind of nonsense it
really is about how Minds activate
bodies
um but it's not completely disconnected
from the analogies that are used and
that's probably what makes it so
difficult for us to understand it is
that in some ways some of the analogies
that we use are proper are proper
analogies because they are really direct
images of what the incorporeal aspect is
representing so let me give you an
example that's very simple which is that
in the Orthodox church we have a
practice which is called the Jesus
prayer and the Jesus prayer is a is a
prayer that you repeat Lord Jesus Christ
Son of God have mercy on me a sinner and
in the traditional ancient practice the
monks would look at their navel or look
at their Center and then they would
Breathe In at the first part of the
prayer they would Breathe Out in the
second part of the prayer and through
that breathing and Rhythm they would try
to make the prayer enter into their
heart and the the prayer would align
with their heartbeat so that in some
ways their heartbeat was becoming the
prayer and so now you have two things
going on here on the one hand you have
the physical action which is the
repetition of the prayer the breathing
the standing still the looking at your
center right the coordination of the of
breathing in spirit and then pushing it
down through attention you know like
breathing and pushing the breath down
into your Center with the prayer that's
a physical action that you're doing but
as you're doing that you are also doing
the subtle action which is you know in a
more in in a more kind of psychological
sense or in a more purely spiritual
sense you are trying to make that prayer
enter into your center of your being
you're trying to replace all the flighty
thoughts all the all the all the kind of
distractions that you have in your in
your being and replace it with that
prayer and so the physical action of
doing this practice is aligned with the
more you know subtle action of entering
the prayer and the thought of Lord Jesus
Christ have mercy on me a sinner
bringing that past your thoughts into
your core into the center of your being
and in some ways replacing your thoughts
replacing all the distraction all the
chaos all the passions with that prayer
so that it becomes in some ways the
basic pattern by which you exist and and
and the pattern of the prayer itself
that is the pattern by which you should
exist which is right an invocation of of
Christ right an invocation of the ideal
and then a recognition of my of my
distance from the ideal right and so
it's like that's actually the pattern of
reality it's a little it's a little uh
hero's journey right it's like you know
you recognize your loss and you come
back to the invocation you invoke you
recognize your your distance and then
you try to remember and come back to
Christ so the idea of remembering God
through this prayer all these things are
all spiritual things that we do they're
all a spiritual practice that we do but
they are in line with the analogical
physical action that we do and that is
what makes the subtle body question
the most difficult to understand is that
it is not completely disconnected from
the spiritual Parts the analogies are
not arbitrary they are they are
important and they can sometimes be very
strict analogy between the two and so
that means that
that means some things that might be a
little tricky for materialists and
modernists to understand that means that
means that
when someone experiences this Aegis type
of agency this type of subtle being it
is possible that they experience them
in a way that is very close to or really
is a seeing or a hearing or a physical
manifestation
uh because the the analogy between the
physical manifestation and the spiritual
meaning is not completely arbitrary and
impossible so what that means is that it
is possible
to see an angel
it is possible to hear you know an uh uh
an angel all these things are are
possible and they don't take away from
the understanding that the way that it
happens is through a kind of analogy
that is it is pointing towards true
incompore Inc incorporealness and true
spiritual realities uh and like I said I
know that that last part is the part
that might stretch you beyond your limit
but if you can't go there yet if you
can't go all the way there you might as
well at least try to understand the
first part uh and that you know
understand that some of these things are
documented in the sense let me give you
an example of an interesting documented
case I forget the name of the missionary
but there was a missionary who went I
think it was in Papua New Guinea or
somewhere in the third world I heard
this from from uh Paul Vander clay and
then I found the story later that forget
where where I saw it though so this
missionaries there with these people
from another culture like a more
traditional culture and the people from
the culture uh say you know
you know the the goddess is appearing at
this place right now the goddess is
there and the missionaries like you know
whatever and so they like take the the
man the missionary to the place where
the goddess is appearing and they're
like look the goddess is right there the
goddess is there on the beach and
everybody can see her but the missionary
can't see her he can't see the goddess
and so you know you could come to two
conclusions which is one everybody is
delusional everybody is having a
delusion okay you can come to another
conclusion which is that those people
have been trained
to
let's say
notice subtle patterns in reality
through which they are capable of no of
seeing with their eyes or the eyes of
their heart at least they're able to see
the agency manifesting itself in front
of them as the the goddess itself uh and
so
all right so I don't think I've ever put
you guys as far as I'm doing now but you
know I think that meditate on it think
about it and you'll see that you know if
you if you watch the discussion where
I've talked about with Rafe Kelly where
we talked about the possibility of
seeing a face in the clouds and that
that face could speak to people and that
that phase could speak to a group of
people they could all see it and it
would all be in some ways a principality
communicating with them and that that is
completely possible and that it is not
doesn't contradict a kind of more
material causalities it has to do with
the capacity to notice subtle patterns
that are kind of manifesting themselves
in the world so so anyways I think I've
said enough and I think I've kind of
pushed you enough feel free to comment
and to engage in the discussion if you
want to also engage in the discussion on
the circle community of the symbolic
world that could be fun to do uh and so
uh so yeah so I hope you enjoyed this
and I hope that it was uh at least a
little useful to you and I will talk to
you very soon bye